un nouveau numéro de votre rendez vous
consacré à la présidentielle en france
france 2022 l'heure du choix comme
chaque soir à 20h15 heure de paris avec
vous je serai de verdure on
s'arracherait bonsoir marion j - 16
avant le premier tour de la
présidentielle et alors qu'il est
distancée dans les sondages le candidat
d'extrême droite eric zemmour s'est
organisé aujourd'hui un déplacement très
médiatique et polémique porte de la
villette à paris un quartier sinistré
par le crack il s'est affiché au milieu
de toxicomanes et de migrants et a lancé
c'est ça la france aujourd'hui une mise
en scène retransmises pendant plus d'une
heure sur la chaîne saigne aux anciens
employeurs d'ailleurs d'eric zemmour les
choses ont ensuite dégénéré le candidat
a été visé par divers projectiles et a
fait l'objet d'un sud cet incident et
d'autres choses encore c'est tout de
suite dans leur cas politique de florent
rodo et julien boutet
c'est l'histoire d'une visite
mouvementée
c'est tout sauf une surprise eric
zemmour n'est pas le bienvenu à la
colline du crack à paris ou dealers et
consommateurs font craquer les nerfs des
riverains je me sens nos mains mais ils
ont un gros mensonge on nomma et sa
solution un deux poids deux mesures il
ya des gens des toxicomanes les offres
sont étrangers il pourrait renvoyer les
autres français il faut les soigner
chasse aux toxicomanes pour l'un chasse
aux voix pour l'autre marine le pen et
son camp drap désormais ouvertement les
électeurs d'eric zemmour on peut
défendre des idées qui sont assez
proches partager des diagnostics
notamment sur la sécurité l'immigration
qui sont assez proches avec un comme
avec l'autre l'autre c'est valérie
pécresse
plus les jours passent et plus le second
tour s'éloigne pour la candidate et
l'air loin dans les sondages parce que
valérie pécresse nous entend elle entend
pas à l'isolément à cause du coc vide
quand ça veut pas ça veut pas je
m'entends en écho dans votre dans mon
oreille et votre caméra mal est en train
de téléphoner donc c'est très très
compliqué pour faire l'interview pour
moi ce soir à valérie pécresse qui dit
non à tout assouplissement de la
législation concernant la culture du
cannabis bah jean lassalle
[Musique]
je sais pas ce qu'on peut faire ou pas
faire afin d'installer
de 300 autorisé au pas m pouces
vous le dire moi je serais pour que
elles savent à nu par l'état et peut
être par les bureaux de tabac qui se
paie ne veulent plus avoir de travail
manière très très encadrée en politique
il faut montrer ses muscles en mma aussi
sur twitter fabien hausse elle encourage
kevin oumar avant son combat abou dhabi
c'est le fils de son ancienne compagne
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve lundi
[Musique]
et un coup d'oeil en cette fin de
semaine aux intentions de vote selon un
sondage ifop publié aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron et marine le pen sont toujours en
tête avec respectivement 28 % et 25 %
jean-luc mélenchon toujours troisième
avec 14 % 11 et demi pour cent pour
valérie pécresse 11% pour eric zemmour
et puis du côté des petits candidats
comme on les appelle trois et demi pour
cent pour fabien roussel 2% temps pour
jean lassalle que pour anne hidalgo et
c'est donc globalement assez stable
marion par rapport au début de semaine
c'est l'un des sujets les plus clivants
de cette campagne présidentielle la
réforme des retraites oui le sujet est
revenu au coeur des débats économiques
de cette campagne présidentielle après
la promesse du président candidat
emmanuel macron de relever l'âge de
départ à la retraite à 65 ans une
proposition à laquelle une majorité de
français se dit opposés selon un sondage
publié mardi dernier et ce débat autour
de la question des retraites on en parle
avec l'hymne les failles ce soir bonsoir
line post malgré la réticence donc des
français à travailler plus longtemps
plusieurs candidats ont fait des
propositions sur le sujet c'est d'abord
le cas du président candidat emmanuel
macron alors il a certes renoncé à sa
proposition de campagne de 2010 est sa
promesse 2010 est d'unifier les carottes
de régimes de retraite français et de
passer à un système unique à points mais
avant même son entrée en campagne en
2022 il a annoncé son intention de
relever l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 65 ans d'ici 2030 de leurs 65
ans c'est aussi l'âge que souhaite
atteindre à valérie pécresse la
candidate du parti les républicains elle
souhaite arriver à ce niveau là d'ici
2030 elle veut également baisser les
cotisations vieillesse sur les retraites
et puis il ya un autre candidat qui veut
relever l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite c'est eric zemmour il veut
atteindre l'âge de 64 ans il veut lui
aussi aligner le public et le privé
d'autres candidats en revanche propose
de revenir à une retraite à 60 ans c'est
en particulier le cas de jean luc
mélenchon le candidat de la france
insoumise qui a fait de la retraite à 60
ans il me dur emblématique de son
programme économique car selon lui pour
vivre longtemps et en bonne santé il
faut s'arrêter de travailler
suffisamment tôt trois autres candidats
à gauche propose aussi la retraite à 60
ans contre 62 actuellement c'est le cas
de fabien roussel pour le parti
communiste de nathalie arthaud pour
lutte ouvrière est également de philippe
poutou pour le nouveau parti
anticapitaliste et puis marine le pen
elle elle veut baisser l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite à 60 ans uniquement
pour ceux qui sont rentrés très tôt sur
le marché du travail a en 20 ans en
revanche ceux qui rentrent à partir de
25 ans sur le marché du travail et
devront travailler bien plus longtemps
jusqu'à 67 ans s'ils veulent une
retraite à taux plein on le voit donc
cette question de la réforme des
retraites polarise fortement les
candidats à la présidentielle en tout
cas il ya urgence à réformer le système
alors ça c'est l'argument qui est avancé
par ceux qui veulent relever l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite au delà de 62
ans ils disent on vit plus longtemps il
faut travailler plus longtemps surtout
qu'il ya un déséquilibre au niveau du
système de retraite français par
répartition à des équilibres financiers
alors si on regarde les chiffres il ya
certes eu un déséquilibre une perte
globale de 13 milliards d'euros en 2020
en pleine pandémie de kovy 19 mai ces
chiffres se sont nettement améliorées
fin 2021 avec la reprise économique
mondiale le trou n'était plus que de 2
milliards 600 millions d'euros et dans
le privé le système complémentaire des
cadres et des salariés enregistre même
un excédent face à ces chiffres les
syndicats disent qu'il n'y a pas du tout
urgence à réformer le système des
retraites en tout cas à relever l'âge
légal de départ et si on regarde les
chiffres et bien les français partent
dans tous les cas après 62 ans à la
retraite l'âge effectif de départ à la
retraite et autour de 63 ans allant de
plus que l'âge légal c'est le résultat
des précédentes réformes de retraites
qui disent qu'il faut cotiser davantage
pour avoir sa retraite à taux plein
merci beaucoup line pour cet éclairage
donc sur les retraites et pour mieux
comprendre tous les enjeux économiques
de cette présidentielle je rappelle qu
on vous retrouve tous les vendredis dans
écoute campagne une émission également à
retrouver bien sûr sur les réseaux
sociaux nous sommes donc à
presque deux semaines du premier tour et
c est la dernière ligne droite on peut
le dire pour les candidats oui et
certains candidats sont très frustrés
ils dénoncent régulièrement l'absence de
véritable débat
notamment ceux qu'on appelle les petits
candidats qui n'ont pas eu l'occasion
d'interpeller directement leurs
adversaires sur des plateaux télévisés
comme ce fut le cas en 2010 est par
exemple alors comment font-ils pour se
faire entendre vous voyez ce reportage
auprès du leader du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste philippoteaux et du
candidat du mouvement résistons à celle
là où d'autres s'offrent des bus de
campagne à leur effigie jean lassalle
lui arrive à paris en camping car
est le candidat de la france authentique
comme il dit ne laisse pas indifférent
son atout
juste une sympathie en fait je rencontre
mon candidat préféré pour le premier
tour et voilà je lui souhaite une bonne
campagne
ah oui qu'est ce que vous en pensez il
n'a pas de visibilité
pour faire parler de lui ces derniers
jours sont la seule à trouver la parade
laisser croire qu'il allait abandonner
la course à la présidentielle bien un
coup de boule à la zidane
pour des à ceux qui s'intéressent et ils
sont si nombreux
enfin ça la politique
réveillez vous l'avez politique c'est
parce qu'on vous montre
[Musique]
peser sur le débat existait autant que
possible c'est aussi le défi que se
donnent le candidat du npa philippe
coûtant des petites en dida ils sont pas
les bienvenus enfin nous en tout cas
avec mes idées anticapitalistes donc il
ya aussi ce plaisir-là de juguler un peu
et puis on dérange alors on sait qu anna
qui veulent pas débattre avec nous et
donc quelque part on se dit qu'on n'est
pas si petit que ça ce matin-là il
profite d'un passage sur une radio
locale marseillais ge pour défendre sa
candidature
notre qualité c'est ça justement d'en
appeler à la révolte et d'affirmer
clairement qu'il faut changer
profondément le système un discours
bienvenue pour cette sympathisante
personnes qui me donne confiance en tous
cas dans dans ce que ça pourrait être la
politique jeu son défi élargir au delà
de sa base militante philippe poutou est
créditée de 1% des intentions de vote 3
% pour jean lassalle est maintenant
notre archive bonus du jour oui en écho
marche pour le climat qui se sont tenues
aujourd'hui dans des dizaines de villes
de france des jeunes qui désespèrent de
voir que le sujet du réchauffement
climatique n'est pas du tout mis en
avant dans cette campagne présidentielle
et pourtant il y a urgence absolue ça
fait même des années qu'on le dit on se
rappelle entre autres de cet
avertissement du président jacques
chirac c'était à johannesbourg lors de
la phase finale du sommet mondial du
développement durable organisée par les
nations unies s'était il y a quasiment
vingt ans jour pour jour regarde
notre maison brûle
et nous regardons ailleurs
nous ne pourrons pas dire que nous ne
savions pas
on n'en garde que le 21ème siècle ne
devienne pas pour les générations
futures
celui d'un gréement de l'humanité contre
la vie voilà c'est tout pour ce soir
mario merci beaucoup aux hlm c'est la
fin de france 2022 l'heure du choix
retrouver aussi sur notre site internet
france 24 points comme et sur les
réseaux sociaux rendez-vous à lundi mais
meurt